Olha a pergunta que eu recebi.
Melatonina ou sim com HTP para sono.
Qual que eu escolho? Sabe aquela
sensação de deitar na cama e ficar
rolando de um lado pro outro, contando
carneirinhos até perder as contas? Pois
é, você não tá sozinho nessa. Estudos
recentes 2024 mostram que mais de 40% da
população adulta sofre com problemas de
sono. E aí vem aquela pergunta que não
quer calar. Será que eu tomo melatonina
ou sim com HTP? Hoje vou te contar uma
verdade que a maioria dos médicos não
sabe ou não quer te falar. Olha só que
interessante. A maioria das pessoas tá
tomando melatonina completamente errado.
Sério mesmo. Você vai na farmácia,
compra aquele frasco de 3, 5 ou 10 mg,
achando que quanto mais, melhor. Tá
vendo? Esse é o primeiro erro fatal. Seu
corpo naturalmente produz apenas de 01 a
03 mg de melatonina por noite. Isso
mesmo que você ouviu, menos de 5 mg.
Quando você manda 10 mgela baixa, é como
se você estivesse jogando uma bomba
nuclear no seu sistema endócrino. Deixa
explicar uma coisa que eu descobri
analisando os estudos mais recentes de
Singapura e da Europa. A melatolina que
você toma na forma de suplemento é um
hormônio sintético produzido em
laboratório. Já o 5 HTP é diferente, ele
vem de uma plantinha africana chamada
grifônia simplifólia. Os africanos usam
isso há séculos, muito antes da gente
sequer saber o que era a serotonina. Mas
aqui vem o polo do gato. O 5 ATP não é
melatonina, ele é o precursor da
serotonina que por sua vez se transforma
em melatonina naturalmente no seu corpo
quando você tá no escuro, quando
escurece. Saca só essa cascata
bioquímica fascinante. Você come um
alimento com triptofano, tipo aquele
peru de Natal ou um bom pedaço de
queijo. Seu corpo pega esse triptofano e
através de uma enzina chamada triptofano
hidroxilase transforma em 5 HTP. Depois
do 5 HTP vira serotonina seu
neurotransmissor do bem-estar. E quando
anoitece essa serotonina é convertida em
melatonina pela sua glândula pineal. É
uma sinfonia bioquímica perfeita. Agora,
o problema da melatonina sintética em
doses altas é que ela pode causar o que
chamamos na visão integrativa de
supressão da glândula pineal. É tipo
quando você toma testosterona sintética
e seus testículos param de funcionar,
entendeu? Então, mesma coisa. Um estudo
publicado em 2024 no Journal of Clinical
Nutrition mostrou que idosos que tomaram
apenas 100 mg de CTP por dia melhoraram
significativamente a qualidade do sono,
especialmente aqueles que já tinham
problemas para dormir. E o mais bacana
não teve efeito rebote nem dependência.
Mas esa aí não é só jogar 5 HTP para
dentro e pronto. A coisa é mais
complexa. O mesmo estudo descobriu que o
5 HTP também melhorou a composição da
microbiota intestinal. Isso mesmo, suas
bactérias do intestino. E por que que
isso importa? Porque 90% da sua
serotonina é produzida no intestino e
não no cérebro. Então quando você toma 5
ATP, você não tá só melhorando o seu
sono, você tá consertando todo o eixo
intestino cérebro. Vamos falar de
dosagem agora porque aqui a galera se
perde geral. Com melatonina, os estudos
mais recentes sugerem começar com doses
baixíssima de 05 a 1 mg tomadas 2 a 3
horas antes de dormir. Não é na hora de
deitar não, viu? É antes, porque a
melatonina precisa subir gradualmente
para simular o que acontece naturalmente
no seu corpo. Já o 5 HTP, a dose que
mostrou resultados mistudos foi de 50 a
100 mg, também algumas horas antes de
dormir. Tem uma sacada genial que eu
descobri nos estudos holandeses. A
exposição à luz azul à noite destrói a
sua produção natural de melatonina. Não
adianta nada você tomar melatonina aos 5
HTP e ficar no celular em meia-noite. É
como tomar remédio para diabetes comendo
açúcar. A luz natural com comprimento de
onda de 400 a 480 nanôm suprime
completamente a sua melatonina nidógena.
Por isso que nossos avós dormiam melhor,
não tinham aquela joça de tela LED
perturbando o ritmo cicardano deles.
Agora eu vou te contar quando usar cada
um baseado no que a evidência científica
mais atual mostra. A melatonina
sintética funciona melhor para jantil,
trabalha em turnos noturnos e para quem
tem o tal do transtorno da fase do sono
da atrasada, que é aquela galera que só
consegue dormir às 3 da manhã e acordar
meio-dia. Já o 5 HTP parece ser mais
eficaz para quem tem insônia relacionado
com depressão, ansiedade ou
fibromialgia. Um estudo de 2024 mostrou
que passa isso com Paxon que tomaram 50
mg de 5 HTP, melhoraram o sono REM sem
aumentar os episódios de transtorno
comportamental do sono rin. Mas olha que
interessante, pesquisadores descobriram
que quando você combina substâncias, o
efeito pode ser sinégérgico. Um estudo
publicado esse ano mostrou que a
combinação de gaba com 5 HTP funcionou
melhor do que cada um sozinho. E tem
gente combinando melatonina com magnésio
e complexo B com resultados promissores.
Mas cuidado, não sai misturando tudo sem
orientação, porque sim com HTP com
antidepressivos pode causar síndrome
serotoninérgica, que é perigoso pr
caramba. Eu vou te dar uma dica de ouro
agora. Antes de sair tomando qualquer
coisa, você precisa saber qual é o seu
cronótipo. Tem gente que é naturalmente
matutino, acorda cedo, feliz da vida.
Outros são noturnos, funcionam melhor à
noite. Se você é noturno e tenta forçar
um padrão matutino com melatonina, pode
piorar tudo. É como tentar colocar
gasolina num carro a diesel. E tem mais
uma coisa que ninguém fala, a questão da
pureza dos suplementos. O Instudo 2025
usando espectrometria encontrou
contaminação com L triptofano em vários
suplementos de melatonina e 5 HTP do
mercado. Doses erradas, substâncias não
declaradas. é um verdadeiro faro oeste.
Então, nos Estados Unidos, esses
suplementos não são regulados com
medicamentos, são considerados
suplementos alimentares. Aqui no Brasil
a situação não é muito diferente. A real
é que não existe bala de prata pro sono.
Tanto melatolina quanto 5 KTP são
ferramentas, não soluções definitivas.
Se você não arrumar sua regime do sono,
pode tomar o que quiser que não vai
resolver. Isso significa quarto escuro,
temperatura entre 18 e 21º, sem
eletrônicos no quarto, jantar leve pelo
menos 3 horas antes de dormir e uma
rotina consistente de horários. Para
finalizar, deixa eu te contar o que os
estudos mais recentes estão mostrando
sobre o futuro tratamento da insônia.
Pesquisadores estão desenvolvendo
agonistas seletivos dos receptores de
melatonina, que são mais específicos e
com menos efeitos colaterais. Tem também
a questão da cronobiologia
personalizada, onde você faz exames para
saber exatamente como está o seu ritmo
psicadiano e ajusta o tratamento de
acordo. Então a escolha entre melatonina
5 e ATP depende muito do seu problema
específico. Se é jeturno,
melatonina e dose baixa pode ser a
melhor opção.
é insônia com componente emocional
intestino desregulado ou fibromialgia ou
ATP pode ser mais interessante, mas
lembra dose baixa, horário certo e
sempre pensando no conjunto da obra. Não
adianta tomar suplemento e continuar com
hábitos ruins.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselente de medicina me limitam. Aqui
eu preciso simplificar, censurar doses,
omitir protocolos controversos e na
comunidade fechada não existe filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica. Casos de reviação
que parecem possíveis, combinações off
label que funcionam, fornecedores
confiáveis, interpretação avançada de
exames. É basicamente ter acesso a meu
cérebro médico sem intermediários. Les
semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF com
47 protocolos exclusivos. Grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a medicina
funcional real, sem simplificação para
as massas, clique em seja membro. Não é
para curioso, é para quem quer
resultados.